I was always hidden comedy but I never I
never got into pranks pranks always
scared me cuz I always yeah I'm always
worried if I pull a prank on somebody
someone's gonna get hurt and I don't
have any time for that but you you like
to pull a prank on people on the set of
witness yeah I can't man here's the deal
we live in a society where you've got to
lock your phone man
you got a your phone is more important
in your wallet you everyone's got
Twitter
everyone's got Facebook if you leave
your phone unlocked I'm gonna tweet from
it for sure I'm just gonna write very
you know things that you wouldn't want
out there and one time we were my ad
always leaves it online i text his wife
i love you baby
you know regular stuff not like crazy
stuff but one time my my eight assistant
director for the show on Whitney texted
me thinking he was texting Whitney I
don't know what he has me in the phone
as but he's like hey we're still good
for that scene how many extras do you
want I was like yo this guy's in for it
so I wrote back forget the scene we're
gonna scrap it I'm in the writers room
right now we need an Asian guy in a frog
costume for Monday and I just left it I
was like ah that's so funny I got him
and Monday came along and we got there
and everybody was like what's this Asian
guy with the frog suit
the ad was like we got a case I got the
guy I got the lorries looking for the
frog costume right now scrambled death
is done yeah they were like we got
central casting on the Asian how old's
you need to be and Whitney was like what
the hell are you talking about now we
talked about it as long as they never
found out it was you do you do this to
like good friends of yours too yeah the
best I found the best guy to do it to I
haven't I have an Italian friend that I
met that I met at this coffee shop I got
two and he's always there and he's just
so innocent in Italian just like yeah he
always looks like he's watching
fireworks he's just like he's just happy
to be here he's like it's so beautiful
it's such a beautiful day and I was like
yeah but when did you get here he says
I've been here for eight years that's
like you've got to quit that face that
you do the toll building he walks around
and he's but so I I'll tweet from his
phone the just things about how do you
have I think you might have a yeah this
is a tweak that you sent this a real
tweet you sent on your friend's phone I
hate my dad makes me sleep hey yeah you
deserve it if I here's the deal I won't
unlock if your phone's locked and I know
the code which I I know the code cuz i
watch yeah
if your phones lock I'm a nice guy I'm a
crook but I'm like I have morals you
know what I mean I won't break into it
right if you leave it that's on you
it's an invitation yeah you do something
that I enjoy which is you you you like
to tweet pictures of regular people that
you see at Starbucks but you say that
they're celebrities and I was looking
somebody it's like this is one you sent
out you said this Anderson Cooper
I think that fun that's right that's
like Anderson Cooper after he gets
cancelled and he loses any lights games
because one is Tom Hardy from Dark
Knight Rises and then this one you said
is Ricky that's like Ricky Gervais see
if you got a role on The Sopranos yeah
my favorites are the ones that really
don't look anything yeah I think them
I'm at the coffee shop like this like
they wouldn't like this I try to pretend
like I'm texting but what's the word for
that when people say P I got you